in July a story began to circulate of a
top secret meeting between Taiwan and
the US a newspaper had published a
summary from a secret meeting in the
South China C at the meeting us
officials had reportedly asked Taiwan to
research and develop biological weapons
in a high security laboratory at the
National Defense Medical Center in
Taipei the report began to spread across
local media in Taiwan the US state
department has denied a report saying
that the US asked Taiwan to develop
biological weapons to develop bioweapons
the only problem none of it was true
this part of what analysts and Taiwanese
government officials say was a Chinese
disinformation
campaign ahead of taiwan's presidential
elections there's been a striking
increase in disinformation attacks
targeting the island which the
government and analysts attribute to
China taiwan's government says Beijing
wants to influence the elections because
whomever next occupies the presidential
palace here is going to dictate taiwan's
relationship with China we have seen the
Chinese uh cognitive Warfare and
disinformation campaign and I think they
have sharpened their tools in this
regard every day we have hundreds of
battlefields about misleading
information on the social media China's
communist government has never ruled
Taiwan but it claims it as part of its
territory in recent years China has
stepped up military exercises around the
self-rule island of 24 million
people now Taiwan is going to the polls
to vote for its next president the two
main parties are the ruling Democratic
Progressive Party which has forged
tighter ties with the US under President
tying W and the opposition Guang which
favors friendlier relations with China
leading up to the vote the Taiwanese
government has seen a wave of
disinformation pointing to Beijing with
many of the attacks designed to cast
doubt on the Island's relationship with
the US taiwan's foreign minister says
these attacks are part of an effort to
influence voters there will all uh be
different kinds of scenarios portrayed
by the Chinese s uh for example they
continue to say that the choice in this
election is in between War and Peace and
if you vote for uh the DPP candidate it
will mean War what are you seeing this
year compared to previous years is it
worse better different and how how
concerned are you about it the Chinese
always try to play its role uh and they
try to influence the outcome of the
election one way or another in the
previous times they went through uh
military threat against Taiwan and this
time around uh we noticed that China has
been gearing up as a cognitive Warfare
and disinformation campaign against
Taiwan as the vote near researchers are
working to identify and counter
disinformation targeting the election
they are trying to manipulate the
Taiwanese people's opinion against the r
party Ethan du is the founder of Taiwan
AI Labs an NGO that uses artificial
intelligence to troll through social
media to identify Trends and instances
of misleading information Taiwan is
number one in terms of the foreign
government for information 11 years in a
ro so in Taiwan uh overall every day
every indiv idual have received some
kind of information mantion Taiwan
receives thousands of disinformation
attacks every day that mirror Chinese
State media narratives in the two months
leading up to the vote a tax peaked at
more than 15,000 a day we believe that
there a consistent funding support to
manipulate the Democracy Count's
election in Taiwan and the reason of
that is is at a very unique
prision between United States and China
Beijing has threatened action against
any perceived moves by Taiwan to assert
Independence China is trying to
influence the election because it
doesn't want this man William lie to win
Beijing sees Li as an advocate for
Taiwanese Independence and it worries
that Taiwan will move further away if he
becomes president Li is currently
serving as taiwan's vice president and
has said he would maintain the status
quo in relations with China established
by President
Tha
[Music]
for The Surge and disinformation comes
amid efforts by Beijing to ramp up
military and diplomatic pressure on
Taiwan but China has denied that it's
trying to interfere in the up coming
election beijing's Taiwan Affairs office
said accusations of Chinese interference
in the election are false and that it
respects the Island's current social
system Chinese leader Xi Jinping has
vowed to eventually take control of the
island making taiwan's status a flasho
in relations between the US and China
whoever wins this election will set the
course of taipei's relationship with
Beijing at a critical
moment